وثق مقطع فيديو متداول عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي رده فعل طريفه لزوجه اشرف حكيمي
لاعب المنتخب المغربي عندما جاء للاحتفال
معها بعد الفوز على البرتغال وظهرت زوجه
حكيم في الفيديو وهي تعاتبه بسبب عدم
احتفاله معها مبكرا حيث قالت له لفات
الملعب واحتفلت مع الجميع وانا اخر من
تاتي اليها للاحتفال نتابع
[موسيقى]
لم يكن احد يتوقع هذا الخروج المفاجئ
للبرازيل من كاس العالم على يد كرواتيا
للجماهير ولا اللاعبون ولا حتى الخصم هناك
لقطه حدثت في المؤتمر الصحفي الخاص
بمباراه البرازيل وكرواتيا عادت للواجهه
بقوه وهي لقطه اقتحامي قطه للمؤتمر الصحفي
الخاص بالمباراه والقاء مسؤول المنتخب
البرازيلي بها على الارض بطريقه قاسيه من
امام اللاعب فينيسيوس حيث اعتبر ناشطون
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي خروج
البرازيل على يد الكرواتيا من كاس العالم
بسببي لعنه القطه التي حلت على المنتخب
البرازيلي
ههه
مقطع فيديو متداول على مواقع التواصل
اجتماعيات ايرانيات يقومن نساء شرطه
الاخلاق ويطردهن من حافله في طهران وقالت
سعيده صورتها مقطع الفيديو النخله وحجابنا
كل يوم ولا نقبل التنمر من شرطه الاخلاق
سننهي نظام الفصل العنصري بين الجنسي
[تصفيق]
مقطع فيديو على مواقع التواصل لحظه خروج
المغنيه الامريكيه باعتي لابيل من المسرح
وهي في حاله » بسبب تهديد بوجود قنبله
خلال حفل لها في مدينه ملوك الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]